la peor pandemia de las últimas décadas
dejó una huella difícil de borrar en
Perú este país cuenta con la tasa de
fallecimientos per cápita más altas de
todo el mundo
667,6 víctimas mortales por cada 100.000
habitantes la Organización Mundial de la
Salud contabiliza que unas siete
millones de personas han perdido de la
vida pero estima que debido al
subregistro la cifras reales de al menos
20 millones de muertos
el continente americano es en donde más
vida se han perdido en relación con su
población seguido por Europa en total
Estados Unidos China India y Francia han
sido las naciones con el mayor número de
casos detectados una cifra que va de la
mano de la capacidad de pruebas para
realizar el mundo desarrolló las vacunas
en tiempo récord y comenzó a aplicar las
primeras de ellas contra el virus en
diciembre de 2020 9 meses después de la
declaratoria de la emergencia sanitaria
global por parte de la OMS para finales
de abril del presente año en todo el
mundo se habían aplicado 13.300 millones
de dosis chile es el único país de toda
América que ha conseguido aplicar el
esquema de vacunación completo a más del
90% de su población África ha sido el
continente con la tasa más baja de todo
el planeta con la llegada de las vacunas
y el mundo comenzó a frenar el impacto
de la pandemia para enero de 2021 se
llegaron a registrar más de 100.000
muertos en una semana mientras que a
finales de abril de este el registro fue
de 3.500 fallecidos en el mismo periodo
el covid-19 no se ha ido la OMS pide no
bajar la guardia pero cuando se
decretará el fin de la pandemia de
acuerdo con la OMS una pandemia
realmente termina cuando la siguiente
comienza